in this video i'm going to be talking
about
how to get noticed on youtube in the
midst of
rising competition going into 2021
and the best way to get your first 10
000 subscribers
and beyond but if you're new to the show
this is coffee with cannell my name is
sean cannell
and my passion is helping you build your
influence
and your income with online video and
youtube specifically i wrote a book
called youtube secrets
and i'm very fired up about this session
because i'm going to be breaking down
three levels that you need to think
about your youtube channel in
in terms of how do i stand out how do i
get subscribers
how do i break through the noise how do
i beat the competition
is it still possible or is it too late
to start youtube right now the answer is
no
but you're gonna really love this
training and in this show we
after the first 15 minutes of content um
we then get into your questions and we
bring you on the show to talk about
how to grow your influence faster but
let's just jump right into it and if
you're fired up smash the like button
wherever you're watching it's good to
see you sasha j
rose what's up wendy let's dive into it
so we're talking about how to get
noticed and get your first 10 000
subscribers on youtube going into 2021
and uh today's coffee with kannel is
brought to you by
our free youtube master class we've
helped multiple people
not just reach 1 000 subscribers not
just reach 10 000 subscribers
but even get that silver play button on
youtube and if you have not watched that
training yet
it's an hour long in detail class and
there's a link in the description or in
the comments where you can watch that
thinkmasterclass.com
and it's entirely free and that'll set
you up for massive success on youtube
going into 2021 but listen
i love this quote from sun tzu that says
every battle is won
before it is fought you know sun tzu
wrote the book the art of war
and this is a quote about strategy that
before
you press record and start making videos
and we encourage you listen
start messy done is better than perfect
start before you're ready
post your next video tell me in the
comments when are you posting your next
video tell me in the comments
how many videos have you posted on
youtube so far you got to take messy
action
and really punch perfectionism in the
face when it comes to starting
but you also simultaneously want to be
creating a strategy
because every battle is won before it's
even fought so if you don't actually
have a solid strategy and an approach to
youtube
then you're never going to achieve the
growth that you want
and that's what we're talking about when
it comes to getting noticed the people
who stand out
i don't believe stand out by accident
the people who hit 10 000 subscribers
they don't get there by accident they
get there intentionally
and so that's what this is really about
and um
this is the most powerful way that i
know to build an audience on youtube and
stand out and it's this
uh three rings of
defining your niche and what makes you
unique on youtube in the first level is
the most
outer ring and that's what you do so
this is going to be an interactive
coffee with kennel i want to know
what is it you do on youtube and here's
the example
if you were to start like a cooking
channel you might get discouraged
because you go there's so much
competition i mean and i don't blame you
so if you like look over here and we
were to type in like
cooking tutorial into the search bar
right you can actually go filter up here
right
and you can go channel just to kind of
get an idea of what other channels are
out there
related to that phrase and so i mean
you're competing with gordon ramsay and
helen's recipes
now i like this what i see right off the
top because she goes parentheses
vietnamese food which is already
kind of niching down that's a good thing
to look at not just general cooking
cooking and crafting the cooking channel
a couple smaller channels cooking
tutorial
and and all these different things and
you go my god how am i going to stand
out on youtube
if all you're doing i don't know if
you've ever seen this channel cooking
with dog
it's a really cool channel where she
always just has her dog
in the shot just sitting next to her as
she's cooking
which which i'm kind of getting ahead of
myself this is a little bit different
isn't it
it's like not only am i going to show
you recipes but i always got a dog up on
the counter
i don't know if that's sanitary and so
you take something like
cooking right and that's what you do so
let me know
what it is you do but if you only ever
um focus on that when it comes to your
youtube channel
not only will you be discouraged but
that's like the lowest level
of focus for a youtube channel because
if you just say man
can i succeed on youtube in 2021 there's
already a bunch of tech channels well
that's what you do
and if you only think how can i beat the
other tech channels and you stay at that
level you'll be super discouraged
but what is it you do let me know what's
your niche what's your topic
and notice that again if you were to
just go cooking channel that's a little
broad but if you were to do just do
vietnamese cooking
better that's a more niche of like what
it is
but there's probably a lot of vietnamese
cooking channels too right so
that also could be discouraging so
one of the first things though that out
of these three tips that we're going to
cover
is if you want to reach 10 000
subscribers
the niche or here in america the niche
you pick really matters like you need to
make sure you pick
a proven and a profitable niche
and that's not the topic for today's
conversation
but we're going to be doing some
training and even putting together a
free resource
of the best niches on youtube the most
when i even say
profitable there's a term we're going to
be talking about on season 2 of the
think marketing podcast starting in a
few weeks
called market viability this is what
market viability is
it's the goal the goal is to determine a
realistic
estimate of future revenues and whether
it's big enough
since it's unlikely that your
organization is operating as a monopoly
you're realistically going to win less
than 100 of customer business so your
question
how big is the market how big is the
niche how many people are watching
cooking videos workout videos uh
gameplay to do like whatever it is
so so when you're picking a proven and a
prop
profitable niche the goal is to
really make sure your what is clear
like the channel i'm starting and
choosing
to build on youtube the niche the niche
that's clear and i've picked a good what
it's only the lowest level
but you need the right what if you don't
have the right what
and there's nobody that's interested in
that content or it's not positioned the
right way
you're always going to struggle and and
so the initial question would be
are there even 10 000 people that would
subscribe to your niche
sean how do i test that go see if
there's any channels bigger than 10
000 subscribers another question sean i
want a million subscribers does anybody
else have a million subscribers in your
niche
and a really good sign is if there's
some channels that have 25 million
subscribers in your niche
hypothetically there's some big tech
channels marquez brandley
brownlee and mkbhd were in tech
and we're at 1.3 million on think media
our other youtube channel
but it's a massive niche so even if we
get a percentage of the market
it's a proven and a profitable niche
there's market viability there
there's a lot of competition in fitness
there's a lot of competition in makeup
there's a lot of competition in beauty
but what are your what's are you doing
budget
drugstore uh makeup affordable
beauty products and tutorials for gen z
females
well now you're getting really niche
down and your what's getting a little
stronger
are there enough people to help you hit
10 000 subscribers or 100 000
subscribers
and to get that silver play button
that's tip number one hit like if you're
getting value and we're going to jump
into q a in just a second
but the next level is you pick
what you do but then you
gotta write down and think about and
strategize how do you do it and what is
what about your how makes you different
cooking with dog
not only are they a particular type of
cooking tutorials
but there's a dog in the shot on the
counter every time that's different than
all the channels that don't have a dog
on there
and dogs are freaking cute man you know
it's pretty smart because when you think
about
the elements of a viral video you ever
heard this
most viral videos have dancing in them
kids or babies in them
animals in them uh music in them like
these are the elements of things that go
viral
you're probably gonna see one of those
things sometimes humor or something
and so when you actually pull a dog into
your cooking show
dude your how just took it to another
level makes sense
if you're how i think about kramer mad
money on traditional television his how
he's got a studio he's got all kinds of
sound effects he's outrageous he's over
the top
there's that cooking channel my drunk
kitchen always like drinking
while cooking you know what i mean
that's a different how
there's there was epic meal time that's
cooking but a whole different
how a style of doing it so tell me in
the comments and even right now this is
some time to get to work on your
strategy grab your journal
and write down like what is it about
how you do it that's different people
approach
fitness differently alina on our team
has got an awesome fitness instagram
that you should follow
and uh she does fitness tutorials how
she does it and even the how of her
style
and even the what of who she's reaching
with her message and all these different
elements
it's just a different difference in the
marketplace never remember
never forget that different is better
than better
so how do you do it here's some trigger
thoughts
it what is what is your style are you
more
controversial and loud and over the top
or are you more conservative and calm
and soothing in your approach
are you more aggressive in if you're
doing a personal finance strategy
channel in your approach to finances or
are you more conservative
that's how um what is your musical
flavors what are your favorite
bands your favorite movies your favorite
pop culture if you're even into pop
culture
what are elements about your how your
how
could be the details it could be even
just how you dress
how you talk where you're from people
resonate
are you uh you know hardcore uh
new york new jersey gary vaynerchuk
every other word is a swear word that's
a particular how there's a lot of people
that give
if you've ever heard of garyvee before
shout out if you ever heard of garyvee
there's people who kind of share what
garyvee is sharing but also don't cuss
every other word you know what i mean
it could be your religious beliefs your
faith beliefs
it could be things you weave into your
channel your how could be the delivery
of your services
the delivery of your youtube channel how
you deliver the content
i always bring you cooking tutorials in
five minutes or less
i always bring you youtube videos in
five minutes or less
we have long conversations like joe
rogan
two hours three hours video podcast or
we have 20 minutes or less in terms of
getting you the content these are all
how
there's a million ways to do things and
i have good news for you
you can reach 10 000 subscribers and
beyond you can get your silver play
button
you can make an impact on youtube still
and in 2021 it is not too late
to start a youtube channel but you
really got to dial in your how
like what is what is going to make you
different and the way to do that is not
to get discouraged or overwhelmed
is to actually look inward and think
about what makes you different
you know for me i try to in our content
a lot of just my personality has come
through in our content i hope
like i'm really into music i used to dj
when i was 16.
i grew up snowboarding and skateboarding
so i watched all kinds of
toy machine and shorty's videos and they
had all kinds of
grunge rock uh hip-hop underground
hip-hop
living legends come on wu-tang clan
hieroglyphics west coast east coast and
a lot of those influence influenced
how i dress influence my style my
personality my
my details you know what i mean like i
don't know some people you're watching
think marketing or you're over on my
facebook page
and like the fact i'm not wearing a suit
some people won't watch this
right like your personality your flavor
how you do it i like to train and teach
i got slides
i got them going through a slide deck
right now that's different
you know i i have a certain style that's
just my how
and it's not something that i just went
out and made up it actually is just kind
of an overflow of my personality
because i've actually taught in a bible
college before
i've i've i've i have to structure my
teaching
in a particular way so there's order to
it's just how i do it
how are you going to do what you do on
youtube
really dialing that in will help you
stand out and a good example of this is
when i think about
uh dave ramsey and robert kiyosaki in
the personal finance niche
now dave is actually killing it on
youtube but of course
he's back in the day from radio and he's
been around robert kiyosaki too one of
the best-selling personal finance books
of all time
called rich dad poor dad let me know are
you team dave team
uh robert or team graham stefan come on
somebody let me know in the comments
uh and so what i think about what do
they do
the same thing is personal and finance
advice
how to get out of debt how to build
wealth how to manage your money
so what they do is the same
but how they do it radically different
super radically different robert
kiyosaki kind of more rough around the
edge
i believe he's a marine he served in the
armed services and so he kind of just
has this like sort of hardcore
uh kind of edge to him a little bit more
controversial although both are pretty
controversial um
but how they do it robert kiyosaki's
gonna tell you to go into debt to build
wealth
i think he's something like 700 million
dollars in debt
and that's why he doesn't pay a lot of
taxes because of the way they have that
set up
meanwhile open up a can of worms and
everyone's mad the president donald
trump didn't pay taxes similar
similar reason because you have so much
debt in real estate and it's the way
you've built it
and and so that's just kind of well on
the other side of the coin
dave ramsey's like dude don't have any
debt cut your credit cards up
pay everything cash except for your
house and if you buy a house don't get
into a house that you can't get into for
a 15-year mortgage
and make sure that that mortgage is 25
of your income or less
which is a particular how and a
conservative approach that has helped
millions of people and both of them have
impacted millions of people because
their how is different
what's your how what is you're in a
niche that's competitive on youtube you
got to figure out
how to be different because how you
teach what you teach
edit like shoot your videos the way you
shoot color
your videos the way you color them
meaning it could be the set it could be
your dress
it could be the the how of the pink like
my friend jennifer allwood
who has the pink glasses and pink
aesthetics in her thing and she kind of
teaches
online business and facebook ads and
some different things and and her
her set and her vibe is it's a whole
unique how
and she stands out online i think about
like my friend chris record who lives
here in las vegas
he always wears an orange hat these are
all just different aspects of how
how do you do what you do that's
different let me know in the comments
and i and let me know if you're getting
value out of some of these thoughts
when it comes to getting your first 10
000 subscribers and beyond
and how you can really get notice and
stand out on youtube going into 2021
but we talked about defining what you do
and you do you're what matters
you got to pick the right what the right
niche the right proven
and profitable niche industry
topic channel positioning okay
personal finance graham stefan robert
kiyosaki
dave ramsey garrett gunderson like
whoever
okay but then how different approach
your proprietary process your framework
your
way of doing it the way you got answers
the way you raise kids
the way you made your marriage work the
way you figured it out
the way you beat final fantasy 7 on hard
mode the way
you do it how but the last one
is your why your why
and if you've not watched it
we'll link it up and we'll share the
link with you
simon sinek's talk and he wrote a book
called start with
why how great leaders inspire action
so at the end of the day if you want
your company to stand out you want your
youtube channel
to stand out you want your um
your business and i hope the bigger
business you're building around your
youtube channel will stand out
you got to pick the right what that's
picking the right industry
like for example right now is the wrong
time to open up
a dvd blu-ray and vhs physical store
where people can rent
dvds from you agree blockbuster
went bankrupt netflix took over
now people are competing with netflix
and you got quibby what are some of the
other ones there's like
niche ones hbo max amazon prime
freaking hulu any who who here
you're watching this even live on the
replay who here thinks they subscribe to
the most
online streaming services i think
i i'm also in this game for us
i'm not ashamed i am ashamed to to go
down the list
i do youtube red i think that's a
no-brainer man i ain't got time to watch
ads and i watch so much dang youtube
content so that's like 10 bucks a month
okay hulu yeah because that's where we
get live tv because we cut the cord no
cable no directv okay what else
amazon prime that's exciting that's a
pass everybody gets a pass on that
free shipping there's other incentives
with amazon okay fair enough
uh netflix maybe a no-brainer uh a lot
of people dump their netflix and their
uh stocks so much controversial stuff in
20 can we just
have a little time of peace here on uh
on coffee with kennel and just
let me know what you're drinking man i'm
drinking some 9.5
ph alkaline water just trying to detox
from 2020
and that's why we're going to crush it
going into 2021 there's plenty of drama
for you to watch on other youtube
channels there's plenty of controversies
for you to watch on the news right now
we're just going to keep it we're going
to stay on the on the main road here
here we go
hbo max raise with wolves dogs come on
man
have you heard of that show we just
finished season one so so we got that
lit
hbo max's subscribers doubled when
raised by wolves
it's a sci-fi show came out and so we
spend 778 dollars a month on stream i'm
just kidding it's not that much but
uh let me know in the comments literally
if you think you have the award
for the most tv subscription services
i don't even know why we're talking
about that start with why
blockbuster versus netflix if you go
into 2021 with the wrong what
and you try to start a channel that's
blockbuster you're going to lose
because it's 2020 freaking won in three
months
right you got to have the right what
then you got to figure out how you're
going to do it how is your original
programming different than the other
guys
how are what are you bringing to the
table to get
my money to subscribe you're bringing
raised by wolves and it's a
freaking dope show got a little weird at
the end there
right what are you bringing to the table
how but then why do you do it
and for most of us when i think of you
watching this you're probably kind of a
personal brand entrepreneur or a
business owner
that is wanting to leverage your
personal brand create extra streams of
income
maybe turn what you know how to profit
from what you know build an online
course
uh build a membership site of some kind
leverage youtube
maybe to do brand deals and ads your why
really matters because the way to stand
out going into 2021
get past 10 000 subscribers is to start
with why
that is even more distinct
in terms of why people will want to
follow you and connect with you
why is what you believe
why is why you're doing what you're
doing so
write this down if you're taking notes
or just or just remember this
people follow people with shared beliefs
frick 2020 made that clear like the
whole country at least here in the u.s
where i'm streaming to you from las
vegas
is all polarized right now right and
people are
gathering around people even though it's
kind of at a toxic level of extremes
they're gathering around people with
shared beliefs and sometimes those
shared beliefs it doesn't necessarily
mean your political beliefs or even your
religious beliefs or anything like that
it might be your shared belief like if
you're connected to think media think
marketing
i believe you probably have a shared
belief that the world is changing and
that entrepreneurship is the future
that there's never been a better time to
build a life in a business
on your own terms and that the internet
and that youtube give you
and me and us a massive opportunity to
build something
better and different for our future kids
and our future families
if you've hung around think marketing
for very long you know that
what we value i think marketing is
things like family
and faith and legacy and character
and inter integrity and ethics and
and just doing the right thing is always
the right thing in being kind and being
helpful
in in giving without expectation and
being generous
in helping others in serving people and
believing that even in business
that when you your income is directly
correlated to the amount of value you
add to the marketplace
and so our goal i think media and think
marketing is to just add massive value
to you
be massively helpful over deliver for
free massive content just like this
stream and this right here
and then eventually you hear about or
you know that we have different products
and programs
and we don't have any hard sales never
have had hard sells in our business it's
like
yeah you want more help you want to go
deeper with us we got stuff that we can
help you
like so so maybe you resonate with that
style there's other styles
there's a there's a thousand different
people ten thousand peop different
people to follow
but listen they have different beliefs
there's some people on social media
flexing champagne and flexing like
chilling with the hoes
that was controversial chilling with
like you know uh
whatever all about themselves all about
greed all about materialism all about
whatever
and and those people that are into that
don't resonate as much
with what we talk about at think
marketing because we're so vocal
about our values and beliefs but it's
just different
if you here's the key if you're not
sharing your values and beliefs at some
level
in terms of why your brand is different
your youtube channel is different what
makes you unique
then you're never really going to
attract
your 1000 super fans that'll grow into
your 10 000 subscribers and then
eventually that silver play buttons that
make sense so tell me
why what is the why at the center of
your youtube channel
people connect with people with similar
values
you know for me i value marriage and my
story
really shifted at 2009 when my wife
almost died
and so i began to
six days in the hospital room by my
wife's side when she almost died
began to start rethinking about future
and how we're going to take care of our
family and how are we going to pay these
medical bills
and so i was desperate to find a way to
make money online build a life on my own
terms
work from home in a home office i have a
brand new baby shawn bradley cannell
who i will uh go you know be able to
burp here in just a second
and bill be able to build a life on your
own terms and so
um that values those values that why
inspired me to first figure out how to
provide for my family but then once we
started making six figures from youtube
and
affiliate marketing with massive
leverage and rank videos bringing in
views while we snooze
and uh income i began to think man i got
to help other people
like i could stop here and settle here
we could let this money just go into a
bank account
kind of travel or we could try to blow
up and go to the next level because now
we're on a mission to help 10
000 people create a full-time living
doing what they love with youtube and
online video
and so i was like man we need i can't do
this alone so we blew up
think media you have heather torres tony
areola
olin olin omar and nolan became one
person
omar no you got alina you got you got a
team because we got a big vision
and so the vision started to get bigger
but our why our mission is what drives
us what
mission is at the center of your youtube
channel and here's the key with this why
as well
people are going to resonate when you
start sharing your shared beliefs and
your values on your youtube channel it's
going to push some people away
but it's also going to attract the right
people but it's also how you're going to
stay motivated
because if you want to win on youtube at
the end of 2020 and going into 2021
you got to figure out how to protect
your mindset and if you'd be so bold and
vulnerable to maybe admit
that 2020 maybe mess with you a little
bit
maybe it knocked the wind out of you a
little bit maybe you got you've been a
little bit discouraged even in 2020 and
it's been hard to get your mojo back to
get motivated
it's been hard to get up and in the
midst of
absolutely crazy intense
tension about what's okay to say cancel
culture
everybody's politically correct do i
need to jump on this do i need to
acknowledge
this trend that trend what the what's
going on is the world gonna melt
if you as a content creator as a
creative entrepreneur as a
purpose-driven person
you gotta really get dialed in on your
why so you can put blinders on and get
your focus back
and build my friend if you follow this
what how and why
and you start building at least one
video a week keep posting those videos
keep posting
that content you got to build right now
but you need to have blinders on
you need to stop worrying about what
everybody else is doing stop worrying
about the competition tap into your why
and say
my family my kids my future is too dang
important
to be dabbling at this i gotta dominate
i gotta really get focused and that why
is what drives you
because i go back to 2009 when my wife
almost died in the midst of a recession
we lost two houses
our church was falling apart some people
stole some money that thing was
crumbling
i was on staff there part time and
and then my wife's house under attack so
i started building my side hustle
and it didn't happen overnight it was
massively discouraging
it was lonely i didn't have anybody i
didn't have coffee with kennel even like
this right here
with somebody saying look you got to get
focused dawg you got to you got to build
this isn't going to be overnight
overnight success is never overnight
but you got to stay focused and keep
working the system
and keep posting those videos but also
get your strategy right
get your stuff dialed and so the why is
what carried me
i really believe you can get to your
next 1 000 subscribers what's your
subscriber goal let me know in the
comments
i believe you can get to 1 000
subscribers in the next three months
i believe you can get to 10 000 in the
next six months i believe but that by
the end of 2021
depending on when you're starting you
could be at 10 000 and beyond
subscribers if you're starting now
i know some of you already passed 10
000. and i think that if you really
look within yourself i think you could
you could discover that self-belief for
yourself as well
but it's maybe on the other side of
getting really focused and really
putting in the hard work
really getting clear on what your what
is figuring out how you're going to do
it and what's going to make
you different and really dialing in your
why so that every day when you get out
of bed and your feet hit that floor
you're ready to crush
it's like rising grind let's freaking go
dawg like it's time to run
it's time to build it's time to do this
thing and this is about having alignment
and my friends let me know if you got
value out of this and what one of your
aha moments is
uh in terms of this particular training
and definitely if you want you can check
out
uh simon's the next talk it's only 18
minutes it's a very popular ted talk
and he has also got a great book but
tell me as a question of the day
why do you want to succeed on youtube uh
why do you want to succeed on youtube
get focus on your goals again i know
it's hard to focus on goals
as we have the fourth quarter right now
to sprint towards 2021
we're in an election year here in the
u.s it's freaking nuts
but you gotta stop worrying about what's
going on all around you that you can't
control and start focusing on your goals
that you can control
how many videos you're gonna upload a
week right
how much learning are you doing and
sharpening of the saw to get better at
your skill sets
what are you learning next are you
learning to make your content better
getting your camera game strong getting
your editing game strong
are you outsourcing you sharpening
strengthening those weaknesses in your
area collaborating who do you need to
email who you need to reach out to
why do you want to succeed on youtube
you got to get that why clear it could
be by the way it doesn't have to be some
deep
altruistic mission it just might be you
want like a dream house better vacations
maybe significance and legacy you want
to start a movement of purpose-driven
leaders maybe
it's the new economy you it's for your
family it's for you it's for freedom
maybe you want to prove your parents or
the haters wrong come on can we talk
honestly
you know what i mean like maybe you got
a chip on your shoulder from high school
like i'm gonna show those guys
i wasn't cool in high school that was
like that was my thing probably
like i was so terrified i remember
freshman year arlington high school
little scrawny kid i wasn't a varsity
football player
i wasn't good at skateboarding i didn't
have many
skills to speak of walking through the
hallways terrified you might have been
like awesome
cool in high school i was terrified
kind of changed once i went to this
different school but freshman year
and so now i remember and i remember i
was waiting tables at red robin a couple
years later
and people having they were coming in
with like their insurance jobs and their
accounting jobs and i was waiting tables
on them
and uh you know drive up and like their
nice suv or something
and i was and i kind of was like
wrestling like i'm serving them
and they're looking at me like not even
acknowledging me i'm like we went to
high school together i was probably
invisible to you but i remember i knew
who you were because you were cool you
were popular in high school
can i be this real and i was like uh you
know and i remember thinking i was like
one day
one day that was probably like 2010
2011.
you know i'm waiting tables at red robin
giving them bottomless fries no this
might have been like 2007 or eight
giving them bottomless fries giving them
burgers thinking to myself like i don't
know what i'm going to do but i'm going
to do something
i'm talking about like why do you want
to succeed and you probably want some
other motivations than just that
but sometimes that motivation or that
chip on your shoulder that could be a
good thing man
and when you really tap into
entrepreneurs that make up make it
sometimes like they're trying to prove
somebody wrong
or they're trying to show they could do
it maybe you just want to live up to
your god-given potential come on that's
a good motivation
becoming all that god created you to be
and striving towards
the greatness that he wove into your dna
maybe
you just love the process but listen
it's gonna take grit tenacity resilience
it's gonna take commitment
and so uh you gotta get clear on your
why let me know in the comments and
we're gonna bring some people on here
for coffee with kennel today
but as we land the plane think things
through
and then follow through that is
uh our thought of the week with coffee
with cannell
get your strategy right get your plan
right get think think about your what
your niche think about your how think
about your why and then take massive
freaking action because commitment is
the foundation
of great accomplishments and today's
coffee with kennel is brought to you by
thethinkmasterclass.com
if you go to thinkmasterclass.com and
you have not watched
uh this was kind of more strategic
there's a very tactical one-hour class
that's going to show you how to get
views how to get subscribers three
different ways
to make a thousand dollars a month on
youtube thinkmasterclass.com
link in the description below definitely
write that down
uh check it out if you haven't watched
it and let's crush
q4 it's time to build let's finish 2020
strong even if you are down by 50 points
100 points
you can still come back in the fourth
quarter i believe
god can do more in your life in the
fourth quarter
than you saw happen in the first three
if you get
focused and really start to put
in the work and thinkmasterclass.com
will give you a game plan of how to do
that if you want to hit that one
thousand ten thousand
silver play button target on youtube
coffee with kennel we're back
my son is 11 13 days old like i don't
know
and uh i'm not just out here trying to
figure things out
um and figure out how to be a new dad
but today
we've got uh susie rose
on coffee with kennel susie and where
are you greetings to one and all
um 2020 is interesting
um what was your question
where are you from and what's your
youtube channel or business
las vegas nevada and i am susie rose
designs
s-u-s-i-e r-o-s-e designs
yeah i just uploaded my fourth video on
friday
i have been working on a contact list
for like
over a decade i have over 25 000
contacts across
all manner of social media and
looking at that i am going to
be doing a new year's eve mystery quilt
quilt along uh quilters like this
and i will be offering the pattern for
sale
afterwards after new year sometime in
january
and uh should i shoot
a little well the fabric directions are
going to be coming out in november i'll
shoot a video for that
the clues will be dropped one at a time
approximately
an hour hour and a half apart from each
other on new year's eve
day usually i we usually start these at
like six o'clock in the morning
eastern time and then
uh there's five clues so i'll drop five
videos in one day
and should i shoot a little
mini ad to put across social media
saying hey this is what i'm doing do you
want to come and play
um i like that idea and i think that you
should do
whatever um you want to do creatively to
kind of engage people and get them
coming to your channel but would it be
okay if i
give you my advice of what i would do if
i was you yes
on youtube so so yeah i mean i think
what you just said was kind of like kind
of like a
sort of like a scavenger hunt or like
five days of content
kind of an interactive uh way to get
it it's kind of interactive because um
what quilters like to do things new
year's eve
a lot of times people stay home for new
year's eve
so a lot of these ladies some gentlemen
um you find out what the fabrics are
you you're given pre-cut uh pre-mystery
cutting directions and then clues as to
what you do next to put this quilt
together
uh happens throughout the day
got it got it so again to me that sounds
more like i think it's defining there's
different seasons of a youtube channel
one
is is like serving your existing
subscribers
um and kind of help but for so for
example coffee with kennel
this particular show is literally so
susie you and i can connect
and this particular type of content it's
good for
depth and relationship and like and
hopefully serving and helping you
as well as everybody else that's getting
to watch the show and kind of getting
that advice
kind of a more intimate place but this
video will never
blow up on youtube this video will never
uh be like a massive
uh you know video that's getting reach
and getting growth to meet new people
first you got to actually meet people
first then you can go deep with them
and so but before new year's which
you've got
three months this is what i want you to
do
um what i would do is i i really want
you are you already familiar with
keyword research
yes so i would be looking for a group
okay great great so i'd be looking for
like
growth type videos that could bring
in i want to say a thousand people i
think you have a thought you could have
a thousand people
by december if you make the right videos
now
and those aren't gonna be this channel
trailer makes sense but it's not going
to be that one
maybe the tula pink and black uh to the
pink unboxing that's smart because we
definitely see
some interest there so this tula pink
may be doubling down on that i like that
uh and
these are good strategy videos because
then i just got 26 pounds of yarn that i
will be hand dying to sell because
2020 totally sucks but these are these
are great what is what is a tula pink
570
versus 770 uh that is actually a sewing
machine
put out by two different sewing machines
putting out by uh
bernina so obviously it might be
expensive you know or you're probably
not going to be those
i have a little bernina and ish this is
only a 350.
the tula pink sewing machines they're ex
the bernina sewing machines are
extremely expensive
and you one of the things i'm going to
be doing um the video on that
this week is going to be five different
ways to gather a skirt by using
different
bernina feet on my sewing machine so i'm
going to be actually
teaching this week and then i have five
videos to drop throughout
october can you do some bernina
tutorials yes that's exactly what i'm
gonna be doing
good good good good so when i'm thinking
when i'm in
your if if i was to give you just again
my straight shooting advice
you want youtube to be a place where you
can express your creativity do some cool
things over the holidays
but if possible i would focus
for the next 12 months on search based
videos like you're doing
and on growth videos i would be focusing
on the next 12 months of getting to 10
000 subscribers
by doing exactly we kind of got into
some of those
like massive tutorials like i think it's
interesting
that look at all these yeah i'm doing uh
the uh what i'm doing tomorrow is
five different ways to gather a skirt
they're going to be five separate videos
and i'll lump them into a collection
once i'm done with them
great great great and and and my thought
again when i because i i'm always
thinking about
leverage what's your goal with the
youtube channel do you want to
make money be able to do this full-time
get some side income
this this whole year 2020 sucks um
i was working two jobs 70 hours a week
paying off my debts hooray dave ramsey
um but in june my boyfriend's mom ended
up in the hospital and i basically saved
her life
because she was having a heart problem
but the doctor wanted to send her home
with anxiety pills because dad has
alzheimer's
so i am kind of a caretaker for my mom
and dad and i've been trying to find a
part-time job that's why i'm
going to be also dying yarn and selling
a hand-dyed yarn to help supplement
until i find a part-time job and do the
youtube videos
so it's it's and i also i have to
in between everything else my car died
and my computer crashed with all my
patterns on it so
i'm going to be downloading my patterns
from the cloud i found them up there so
that's good i now uh monetize my
um wordpress page and fiber is my bag
is my blog i also turned it into
suzuro's designs
so that's been monetized i just signed
finish signing up for mailchimp on
saturday so i got that hooked up to my
page so
and i'm almost done designing a landing
page
for when you sign up for mailchimp
so yeah so so i i like it all
um first of all you know again just
sorry to hear that i know 2020 is
impacted a lot of people and i'm sorry
for
everything you've gone through when when
god gives you lemons you make lemonade
that's right you're making lemonade and
i love your attitude and your
perspective
this is what i say tell people all the
time no matter what your dream
whatever your dream make it happen
you keep something you can always depend
on is change
nothing will ever stay the same
and you gotta roll with it pick up and
keep on going
when you fail fail forward get up
and do it again use your stepping stones
and
failure to your success come on susie i
love it you have to do it
hey that's that's encouraging to me and
uh everybody else on here as well and so
hey as we land the plane
um you're in a season
where you got to get ridiculously
focused and i want to say this to you
and everybody watching coffee with
kennel right now
yeah you got to get ridiculous on my
board it says focus
follow one course until successful i
wonder who i got that from
there you go come on follow one course
until
successful and and when i think about
the reason why
making really smart strategic youtube
videos first is so
powerful is because when you get some of
those
bernina tutorials ranked and getting you
views
when you're taking care of your mom
uh or your partner's mom when you're
you know having to do some of the
crafting
on the side and selling those to pay the
bills you want
your side hustle the youtube channel to
be growing
on autopilot and i know that's just kind
of our core thesis but it makes me come
back to say okay
i really need to make sure i put at
least one good video out a week maybe
more than one
and potentially for a time maybe even
the next three months
who cares about the mailchimp for now
possibly who cares about some of these
other things for now
what is the focus what is the laser
target
this is a good theme for this coffee
with candle for everybody what is your
call it a 90-day sprint let's really
call it a 60-day sprint because by the
time you have weekends and by the time
you got other responsibilities we've got
60 days left in 2020 friends to get
serious traction
but you can't chase four rabbits and
plan on catching either of them
what's the one rabbit and that might be
that really smart video each week
or it might be like a series of it you
might sit down and make all these like
look at these they're
they're 50 seconds i have
uh there's like i have pin tucking feet
that i'm going to be teaching
how to do a pin doing a on a shirts
duplicate talking and i have all kinds
of teaching videos
i have a list of over 40. when are they
coming out
when are you going to be making those
videos and when's the next one get
posted
they get posted friday at five o'clock
p.m
and uh the next one is gonna be
on uh it's gonna be one of the five of a
series
of how to use different bernina feet on
how to gather a skirt
awesome well hey a lot of people don't
don't like to use these because they
they don't know how to use them and
you're here to help
i've been doing this since i was a kid
so there you go i had no choice
is teaching i love to teach so this is
this is what i'm going to do
well you're in you're in a perfect uh
you're in a really good niche
in in light of today's training your
what is clear uh
how you're gonna do it you've got the
machine you've got some of the videos
that's unique keep letting your
personality come through
and then of course your your why dialed
in that but let's get focused
and uh do you have a little bit of
clarity and inspiration after this
little talk we
today oh yeah oh yeah just
watch uh basically
instead of some of the other videos that
i had i'll put those
further down the road like i said i got
like 40 videos
on my list of things to do and i'm so
i got four of them crossed off yeah with
everything else i was out of internet
for three weeks so
it was just between my first one and my
second one three weeks
like no but yeah we're gonna i'm gonna
dial down
what i was gonna do just continue what i
was doing with the
teaching videos this week i'm gonna bat
shoot them tomorrow
and edit the first one get it online
and then edit the others and then i'm
going to do a video we got
a how to use a ruffler for foot versus a
gathering foot
so we'll do a versus after those versus
videos
yeah awesome suzy well hey i appreciate
you so much
and thank you very much guys i really
i found you guys thank you i have
learned so much
since i joined all of this in may thank
you thank you thank you i really
appreciate
everything you guys have done for us i
appreciate you as well susie thanks so
much for coming on coffee with kennel
thank you my friends
man how inspiring is susie man she's got
a dialed she's batch producing tomorrow
she's gonna start putting out some
teaching videos
here's a huge takeaway number one you
only got like 60 days left in 2020
i know that there's more time but let's
be honest once the holidays hit
come on you're going to start drinking
eggnog hanging out with family
and taking naps and eating turkey and
cranberries right
once the holidays hit you're going to
have in-laws in town things will be
crazy
um you got stuff to do things to
do you know weekends when you subtract
weekends
when you subtract the last couple weeks
of the year when you suggest subtract
life and some of the things that are
going to come up
you got about 60 focused days in 2020
but here's the good news what would
happen if you got
laser focus on exactly what you want to
accomplish
in a 60-day sprint head down
building shooting videos and here's the
key if you look at it in terms of that
there's certain things i need you to
punt into 2021. that's a cool project on
my to-do list i'm going to do that later
oh i want to write a book cool don't
write it now write it next year
build your audience and influence first
oh i want to do this or that
punt it into 2021 what are you going to
focus on
for this 60-day sprint
you can probably only really accomplish
one significant thing
and in my opinion growth should be the
goal
so what we were talking about with susie
is like don't worry about
going deep with people yet actually
reach some people first
by focusing on videos that will grow
your influence search search-based
content
content that will attract people that
are into quilting
and here's one of the things we like to
talk about at think media
go make some chaos first and then
organize the chaos later
for you planners and you perfectionists
sometimes you want to get everything
right i need to get my website built
i need to get my page set up i need to
make sure my logo is right
forget all that crap like that comes
later
you want to actually have so much chaos
happening
that now you've got problems that you
need to fix
you actually need to go create problems
if you don't have any people yet
if you don't have any momentum if you
don't have your 1 000 subscribers or 10
000 subscribers yet
why are you worrying about your website
like build
momentum which comes back to shoot
videos one video a week it needs to be a
good video a week
strategy get dialed in and when you're a
solopreneur
also take care taking care of family
members that may
be uh ill when you're a solopreneur and
your car breaks down
and you've got other things going on you
don't got much time so you got to be
so focused on your time when you have a
new baby that's 13 years
days old all of a sudden your whole
concept of time gets thrown out the
window
like is happening to me right now with
my new son you gotta really get focused
on time
and chase after that goal so tell me in
the comments what do you want to have
happen in the next 60 days
drop that in the comments what is one
what is your 60 day sprint goal maybe
that you're thinking about right now
you're getting clear on right now
we're gonna bring joshua ryan blair on
coffee with candle today
my man joshua where are you from
what do you do and uh how can i help hey
sean appreciate it
uh can you hear me okay yeah okay i'm
traveling i got some earbuds so i'm kind
of winging it here
um yeah so i'm actually from northern
indiana
like i said i'm traveling but uh my
channel i just started actually the
first week of the youtube challenge
cool so it's pretty new and
it's has to do with aviation and there's
lots of i guess the thing that i'm
i guess fighting most is as far as
getting known and influenced in aviation
where a lot of people like to put out
um crazy videos and very unsafe
flying i mean that's what gets views so
people like to do
crazy things so um basically what i want
to do
um let me say three things so i don't
ramble here i actually took notes
um my end goal actually is to
be able to work from home and have an
engine overhaul
shop i'm also an aircraft mechanic along
with a pilot for 19 years
and to start with that i wanted to be
able to influence in the aviation
community and i wanted to
build an influence of providing safety
and kind of tying that to my personal
brand
and just being safe as a pilot and be an
advocate for
safe flying and being a trusted name in
the community so later on i would launch
you know my business
um as i'm slowly developing
so this last video here was just one of
my shorter videos
i was just trying to use a uh you'll see
a blair tip in there
i think it's in the first minute or so i
was trying to
implement something this is a safety
this week
but it was kind of testing waters with a
blair tip
and i would implement some safety things
in there to kind of make it
attractive because safety really
unfortunately isn't too attractive
yeah no i i love it and so the question
is how to stand out and grow
yeah yeah doing the dangerous stuff that
is people are going to go viral or
whatever yeah exactly i mean i've done
some networking i know some people
in this niche that you know are very um
well known that i've personally met and
talked to and i actually did a live
stream with one guy
so i'm looking to do that it's just i
actually got cancelled it was actually
last month i was hoping to
have an interview with him and his wife
he's a serial entrepreneur
super awesome guy i actually met at
airshow last year
we just haven't connected yet yeah can
you just set it up again even if it got
canceled just another time
yup i'm actually going to email them
tonight it was on my list to uh to kind
of ping them back and
touch base with them so i like it
and um and then who's your ideal
audience and coffee with kennel
community
either write that down or drop that in
the comments it's hard to grow if you
don't know who your
ideal subscriber is so i want everyone
to subscribe listen if you try and reach
everybody you end up reaching nobody
nobody so tell me who's your ideal
subscriber what kind of audience do you
want to reach
uh well i want to reach uh i guess it
would be
i mean obviously pilots and aircraft
owners
that would be i guess one maybe a broad
answer would be pilots and aircraft
owners
but um would you include inspiring in
that or not would that mean that you're
you're your subscribers they either need
to already be a pilot and already own an
aircraft or would you
also say that maybe if they aspire to
become a pilot and aspire to maybe own
an aircraft
would that also include definitely it
would be and i've i mean i've had a lot
of i mean i've given a lot of people
first time rides and
i tried to inspire others and i have in
the past is a couple of young guys
actually
dropped out of the flight program this
year with the whole you know 2020 stuff
going on and
they've actually changed gears to kind
of like aircraft maintenance which is
actually my end goal is uh developing
you know the maintenance community
um but i guess one one question i guess
that brings me to another question
beyond the first one was is do i you
always say
start with the end goal in mind yeah now
how far
did the end go to you go i guess is kind
of what i'm trying to figure out
you know do i i shouldn't say do i mess
with the safety thing yes i want to
always be a good
you know steward of flying safe but do i
kind of jump more towards the
mechanical side and actually start you
know doing more
maintenance tutorials actually my
biggest video which is
it's big for me it's almost getting hit
500 views a month ago
is it was simply a walk through video it
was a
inspection what i do before i fly the
airplane
so yeah um i don't know if i'm geared
more towards
the maintenance and just kind of hey how
close to the end goal i guess
yeah one of the questions great question
so
a couple things one um you actually want
the the longer term you can think
the better because you want to play
things out
um this goes deep but it's really what
is it that i want to build
what eventual business do i want what
eventual
lifestyle what is my what is my end goal
what is my vision
wisdom comes when we actually you know
foolishness
is when you only think 24 hours ahead
i'm at a wedding there's a table of
desserts
let me just eat them all because it's
going to feel good in the moment well
that's a short-term decision because
you're only thinking about the moment
you wake up with the stomach ache
you start adding on 10 pounds over the
next little bit if you
have a vision of i want to be one
i i want to have that beach body six
months from now well that's going to
make that's going to affect your
decision
at the desert table and the bar at the
wedding
but if you also have even bigger vision
man i want to be in my prime and health
so that my son sean bradley's children's
children can get to know me i'm
shoot i'm already 37 so like about to
turn 37
so i i need to live to 120 i better
start getting healthy well now
i'm thinking i'm almost 40 i'm thinking
83 years
ahead in terms of my decision of whether
or not to eat the desserts at
the wedding table so long-term thinking
does help us bring wisdom but then it
also can paralyze us
because the next thing we have to do is
break it down into what's the next
best step and know that there's going to
be phases and i probably don't need to
worry
about the you know 80 of those phases i
need to come back
and do the hard work and roll up my
sleeves because it's fun to dream
i want to be a best-selling author i
want to have a million subscribers and
get a gold play button
i want to be you know one day collab
with oprah
i want to one day start my own church oh
you know
like whatever our ultimate goals are um
but uh then you bring it back to well
today
it means that i just gotta grind and
post my next video you know what i mean
like whatever's practical
in specific advice to you i don't think
being safe in aviation is
a niche i think that's more of like a
personality trait
that people will learn by seeing your
approach
the reason that'll come across is
because you're just not gonna do a
dangerous
uh threatening fatality you're just
never gonna do it eventually you'll
become
known for the guy who like always
is is safe etc you said it
if you want to start an engine overhaul
shop and your most popular video has
already been a mechanical video
you just came to the light bulb moment
yourself you should be doing the
mechanical videos
because they're going to attract people
that want to fix
problems that want to know the
mechanical tips which could eventually
lead even if you don't start your engine
overhaul shop
for five years it's it's awesome to
start
today with videos that will start
moving you towards and building an
audience and eventually building an
email list and eventually building a
brand and a reputation
and all those things so yeah if you go
engine overhaul shop
2022 or 2025 whatever
then as much as possible you start uh
making videos that would lead to that
end does that make sense
yeah it totally makes sense that's
actually in the last couple days i've
been looking at the one video that took
off and it's like i wasn't even flying
but then aside from that even stepping
back more
you know when people ask me you know
what do i do what really inspires me
what
what drives me is really um
his detail and restoration
like i built my own house i hired out
the concrete and the septic system
like i built a hangar home i have a
private strip i've taken me seven years
to do it but
i've done every single thing that was
needed so
um but i love restoration i got my first
car when i was 14 and a half years old
i had it ready my 16th birthday went
back to school after i got my license to
show it off
i mean um i'm i mean i completely ripped
the car apart
so i think that i mean i've really been
thinking like well my i guess grind or
my
whatever you want to call it is
restoration now the passion
just shows up in it and i have a and i
have the way to
articulate it in a way to connect with
people because
um i live it i guess that's what i'm
saying so um
no i love it so so i would say and and
just a couple things as we land the
plane joshua
is like these are all brilliant video
ideas like creating an ideal hanger
uh workshop this i you know research
kind of what's out there
so so you love like this has 30 000
views and it's probably still getting
views
um a little time lapse of a hangar you
know that's a track these are all going
to of course attract
so that's good i do think i was
interested in just again like how to buy
your
first plane um potentially
it could be maybe how to buy and ref
like rent or buy
55 000 views success leaves clues
so it is being aware of what um you
already are going to be going in a
different direction but you still want
to know
you got your own unique flavor with the
maintenance uh with potentially the
the diy build the hanger et cetera but
success leaves clues i would look at
some of the different video ideas and
then it's just about kind of hitting
them all
because youtube is kind of like fishing
you're each video is if you've been if
you've ever been to a pier
i was up in seattle hanging out with
family and my mom and i went to a pier
before we got on the ferry to go to the
san juan islands
and um we were kind of standing there
and looking at all these people fishing
early morning
and one dude had like multiple fishing
poles right
so like he had him all set up um and he
had multiple running so that he could be
multitasking in case one got a bite he'd
grab it he'd start
reeling it in and uh he was out there
fishing youtube's kind of like that the
more videos
you get into the ocean of youtube that
are strategic
search based well-optimized that are
going back to your point attracting your
ideal audience your ideal subscriber
then over time and going all the way
back to suzy rose
then then you're building that base
especially because you're in those early
days of your youtube channel
that gives you a massive foundation of
influence
for whatever you want to do in the
future so you have your engine overhaul
shop
other things you want to do and what's
cool though about having the big vision
that's even like 100 year vision
is it can change but at least you kind
of know where you want to go but then
you come all the way back and you do
you focus on just the needle mover right
now which when it comes to youtube
it's posting that next best video it's
posting that next
strategic video it's dialing in that
contents posting as many videos as
possible
because like my homie on the pier he
didn't just have one fishing pole he had
multiple fishing poles out the more
good video you can get out into the
world potentially attracting your ideal
audience the better
yeah cool i appreciate it real quick
give me maybe 20 seconds here
just real quick i haven't missed a week
since the
youtube challenge i post a video every
single week nice um so i'm thankful for
that
and continue that don't see it in for
that and then also
my only other question going back to
uh doing more of the walkthrough
tutorials and kind of like really what i
have a passion for
how do you feel about like actually this
weekend i'm going to be going on a
flight trip
um like a camping trip airplane train
camping trip and a lot of people like
that
should i as i move forward um
is it okay to or how much is a good
balance
for to throw in some kind of like the
vlog style adventure here's my flight
i mean with this uh more of the um
uh walk through tutorial information you
know
uh videos yeah i think that um
i think that as long as you stay on this
aviation niche
uh i think you're good and the video i
want you to watch
uh after this to get an idea of a vlog
is check out this guy
seth james so this is a perfect example
of how youtube and this is obviously
you're not in running but this i'll
explain
kind of the power of this so you want to
attract people that are into aviation
and i would argue you should attract
people
that are not just pilots and aircraft
owners but aspiring pilots and aircraft
owners okay
so i've been getting into running over
the last couple years i am a
two-time half marathon runner i want to
run a full marathon i'm a little bit
intimidated
i i don't want to just finish i could
probably finish today if i went and
started running
but i want to actually like run it
decently fast i want to build the
fitness for it
so i started watching youtube well now i
know
seth you know what i mean like so now i
know seth
i started i found him because of
suggested videos because of search-based
content
because of maybe searching a specific
shoe etc
and um i started to you have the chance
to reach somebody um when you post out a
video
and then your vibe attracts your tribe
so eventually i'm like okay i like his
energy i see
what he's uh i like his style and so
i don't know i think if we go uh let's
see here he does vlogs and this is what
i want you to watch as we land the plane
his vlog is him maybe
um running like at first
let me see here he he he will start out
he'll take you with him
and he'll kind of do a vlog and then
typically and i can't think of the exact
video but she can get
it's cut he's teaching throughout it so
i would always bring it
bring it back to uh i think what i
learned from him was was maybe
like uh breathing or something and
and he like took me with like run faster
up hills first thing he did was kind of
vlogged and took me with him i was kind
of fascinated
yep i watched this whole thing so it was
more like him trying different shoes
kind of doing some stuff
and then he ended up back in the studio
with all that footage
and was like hey here's some takeaways
here's what i think about the shoes
here's some tips for uh you know
um what i was doing when i was running
up these hills et cetera
and again i'm his ideal audience now
because i'm an
aspiring already kind of like a pretty
pretty serious
hobby and maybe amateur runner that
wants to level up
and so when the student is ready me the
teacher appears
on youtube because of putting out that
good content and so i think that's the
best way to do vlog content
is i'm kind of like okay i'm seeing he's
he's doing it he's a practitioner
and then at the same time i'm leaving
the vlog with
learning how to breathe better learning
about form better
learning about uh a shoe i might want to
invest in does that make sense
yeah yeah i can point something out
maybe after i do and landing at the
campsite or something i can walk around
the plane and say hey
i had a little fed a little something
coming in or just whatever you know
and just kind of give a close-up look at
the airplane and some detail and
mechanicals
so 100 percent man i love it hey i
appreciate you uh joshua thanks for
coming on the show
i appreciate it thanks sean see you
peace
all right coffee with kennel we are i
think going to be able to get one more
on here smash the like button if you've
been getting value and
i want to encourage you um we're on our
60 day sprint y'all hashtag
60 day sprint we're gonna finish
2020 strong and if you need some help
doing that
and you want a game plan for how to
really win on youtube
and you um haven't seen our free one
hour master class today's coffee with
channel is brought to you by
thinkmasterclass.com if you want to kind
of learn a little bit more about the
strategy i was just breaking down
creating search based content getting
your videos to show up in suggested
videos
how do i know which videos to make how
do i know if i'm doing youtube
right um if you don't have confidence if
you kind of feel like you're wandering
uh when it comes to youtube if you're
sort of unsure
about which videos to make which videos
will cause your channel to grow
you've got to watch our free one-hour
master classes totally free
um at the end of it we talk about our um
coaching program called video ranking
academy but whether that's right for you
or not no big deal
you just definitely want to check out
this free master class because this is
going to give you the blueprint
for winning on youtube over the next uh
couple months
finishing 2020 strong and going into
2021 with massive momentum link in the
description in the comments
thinkmasterclass.com we've got uh
josephine coming on
uh the coffee with kennel show today
josephine
where are you from what's your channel
about and how can i help
hi sean can you hear me yeah how's it
going okay
cool well i am over here in beaumont
texas
um and my channel is called josephine
huang it's
pretty much about educating new moms on
the journey to pregnancy and motherhood
from a registered nurse's perspective
nice
and so i just posted or i guess i'm
starting this is my second month
so i posted 11 videos um
one video a week and so i guess my
question
is i'm an inner circle so i'm wondering
you know i know that there is a uh
about 30 to 50 videos where you start
really getting momentum
uh you know i guess my question is
right now i'm doing a ton of educational
videos like
you know i just finished a series on
safe medications for
pregnancy uh i'm about to shoot another
series
on how to conceive and some best
conceiving practices
um so i guess my question is
do i continue just to do educational
content value or do
can i like randomly mix into some of my
personality
personalities such as like some fun
videos i'm like
nurse reacts to you know grey's anatomy
tv show
because that's like super popular and
viral right right now
what are your thoughts yeah i think
you're on it so looking at your channel
and thanks so much for being a part of
inner circle
and uh you're first of all just want to
encourage you you're off to like
an incredible start you're still you
know very early
and the consistency is great and it does
take time to kind of trigger the
algorithm and get things going
i think what's what's cool is just
knowing uh
my sixth sense of youtube
already having a 1 000 viewed video and
having this one that of course is that
vulnerability is that storytelling
the 77 likes on a 1000 views the 21
comments
this is already even the four healing
tips after miscarriage it's cool to kind
of see
a little bit of just ranking and the
terms uh
in there uh success leaves clues so i
think there's something about um
about miscarriage as a key
word you know not to to reduce it to
that but you to of course understand
what i mean
um because that's such something that so
many can relate to
so this is also so there's one thing a
couple levels
one there's lots of different good video
ideas you can make
our challenge everybody at coffee with
cannel is to brainstorm maybe a lot of
different eye video ideas
then ask well which ones are the best
video ideas especially when i have
limited time
and then the even better question is
like okay well if there's 20 of the best
ones which one should i make actually
next
and so um you especially early on
you kind of want to scrape the cream
right off the top like if
there's tons of video ideas you really
just want to focus on those ones that
potentially can move the needle to the
most
that one's interesting to me i think
you're absolutely on the right track
with sort of maybe entertainment
slight education you see it's a trend of
course do the grey's anatomy thing
key is we call it bridge marketing at
the end of the video
you may say something like so hey i hope
you enjoyed this and and
um you know it was fun kind of looking
at the
the good points and the absolutely
incorrect medical points
from grey's anatomy and by the way every
week or every tuesday i upload a video
that actually
really gives you practical advice for
and that's the bridge because what
happens is maybe one of those videos
goes viral
but it's not actually going to probably
attract a lot of people that want to
watch your channel that's fine if you
got a million views
maybe 10 000 out of them are like
i wanna be joseph and josephine superfan
um
because you give an invitation at the
end and always call back
people back for that core um uh
center of what your channel is about but
that absolutely would be on brand
um i do think things that are relatable
because you already now have 161
subscribers it's already a base of
people that maybe want to know
things about your mindset about uh the
relate to you
etc but you asked the question you said
you know should i
pull more of my personality into it what
i would challenge you
is there's no reason why your
personality
shouldn't be in all of your content and
i learned this a couple ways i learned
this one
kind of as making a mistake where i went
so hardcore and search-based
content for a while that i wasn't
um really weaving my personality into it
but i actually realized that at the
beginning i was i'm gonna give you a
quick example
um and then and then tie this all
together
so that uh you can kind of see what i
mean
you can still teach something um
but yet have your humor and personality
in in
it and way back in like 2010
um i did a video about how you can adapt
nikon lenses nine years ago to a canon
camera
and here's what i mean let's just watch
this for a second
yeah stephen yeah steven listen to me
tell george that he's gonna need to do
the shoot just the way that i told him
yeah i gotta go
i gotta do a video all right talk to you
later
[Music]
always some drama with berg and lucas
[Music]
test check what is
up think media tv helping you move
further
faster in media i'm sean
and today i just want to talk about
getting the
most bang for your buck the highest roi
return on investment for lenses for your
hd slr
which is essentially adapting nikon
lenses
to your canon eso body in the midst of
this whole thing my goal is to save
you money because as you know the reason
money is called dough
is because we all need it you'll get
that later so if you're anything like me
you saw the huge potential
hd okay so the reason to share that is
first i was doing dad jokes in 2009
apparently or nine years ago because
the reason you know money is called
dough
is because we all need it okay and okay
i didn't need to explain the joke
maybe actually some people like oh need
that okay bad joke dad joke
so point is i this video got 77
000 views because it was about how to
adapt an adapter for adapting classic
canon lenses to a dslr body um i think
that beginning personality part
people saw that i had like a humor side
like a joking side
and yet it was still based around of
course education
and then for a while this is the mistake
that i learned was again i just got so
focused on
um yes maybe a little here and there but
i i
i just got busy about ranking about
search
and i and maybe i'm trying to survive
i'm trying to like get
the business growing and so on and so
forth and a lot of times my personality
didn't come through in fact
until even more recently with doing live
streams and whatnot
somebody was like i didn't realize sean
kind of was cynical or sarcastic and
joked around sometimes
just because i didn't weave it into my
content so i want to encourage you
one of the best ways as you're helping
people
um and particularly new moms and
soon-to-be moms or moms that are
thinking about it
is to weave in your personality all the
time
and let's make it practical let me give
you some percentages what makes a video
i think fail is when
it's light on education and heavy on
personality when someone's just getting
to meet you
if you have like you tell a long story
all this kind of stuff people like get
to the freaking point like i want to
learn the training
so i almost feel like every video you
should weave in at least 10 to 20 to 30
of your personality meaning a little a
little bit of a so you have to tell the
whole story but you go
you know for me a few years ago this is
what i experienced and i really made
this huge mistake
and that's why i then learned this and
so let's get into it it could be like 15
seconds but like
weaving in your story weaving in your
personality
weaving in something like are you a fan
of the kim
kardashians like i am like maybe you
know whatever but like
weaving in these little moments like in
this very stream
i dropped final fantasy vii remake which
i beat
everybody uh and now i play no video
games because i have a kid
uh sure i got a new board i'm trying to
figure things out and so i dropped in
like wu-tang clan hieroglyphics and
um you know hip-hop and underground and
snowboarding like i like so
these are pulling some of these elements
in and coffee can i want you to hear
that
you should be weaving in
hobbies things you're a fan of uh
little stories but the key is early on
just small bits of it because you want
to be heavier on delivering the promise
of the title
delivering the promise of whatever but
what will happen
josephine is that those become magnetic
don't they like we love to connect with
people like oh
i get her like she's like wow oh that's
funny
you'll probably attract most of us do we
mostly attract
audiences that are about five years
older and five years younger that'll be
the biggest spike in our demographics
and youtube of course like we have
people at all age ranges but it's like a
pyramid down
you will attract someone so chances are
like the songs you thought were cool in
high school will attract other potential
new moms
they'll be like oh yeah i remember that
i've heard that boys casey and jojo
all my life whatever like you know what
i mean so
um i want to encourage you to do to do
both i hope that all made sense
in terms of weaving in your personality
i think your your channel will be
magnetic
really go heavy i think on search based
i think um
vaccines are interesting like these we
have a new baby literally
this first year they want us to give our
baby
68 vaccines or something so we're
researching them all
like dear god and so uh like
all these different topics and just
pumping out videos because you're always
one video away
from that video potentially growing you
know blowing up your channel
um yes to some of the viral
entertainment ones
yes to a story one be okay with that
because people might just be like i
don't want to click on it
that's fine they maybe just want more of
your education you're at a stage where
you should be experimenting
search-based maybe more story people get
to know you
but the best recipe in my opinion i
really like the grey's anatomy idea but
is also
hitting some of those key questions
practical things with a little bit of
personality peppered in
like 20 like a little joke here a little
story here
a little thing here something in your
background here because those are the
subconscious things
but it's just not too much up front and
let me land the plane if you got another
question let me know but
on um it also when you're starting out
to like what you're doing
shorter is also longer as well so when
you're just starting out
you don't want the story of someone's
whole life
you want just the speed dating version
of it you're at a step you're at a stage
in your channel where people want to
speed date you
they don't want to go on a one week
vacation around the world
it's not that level of commitment yet
like my god so that's also the
difference like we're at
we're at one hour and 30 minutes when
the coffee with kennel let me know in
the comments if you've been here the
whole time
most people didn't just like see this in
the feed and we're like yeah i'm just
gonna chill with this dude for 90
minutes let me know if you did but
chances are it's like it starts with
bite-sized digestible
be brief be bright be fun and be done
even when things are short you can
pepper in personality but it's only
10 20 of five minutes that attracts kind
of that core audience
but in the journey of what you're gonna
build eventually it's hour-long q a
and like your die hard community your
super fans
will will be there to hang out and
really connect with you is that making
sense
yes absolutely i do have one more
question this may be a little bit more
specific to maybe inner circle but
um so currently i'm building my digital
course right now
and i my question is how much content
do i give out for free without giving
too much
on what my digital course will entail or
we'll disclose that's great so for
anybody that wants to create an online
course let me know in the comments
if that's an ambition of yours we'll
talk about it in another video
i think everybody should uh package
promote and profit from what they know
the e-learning industry is growing to be
a billion dollar a day industry by 2025
and so the big question though is how
much do i give away for free
on something like youtube and how much
um
do i save for the course so a couple
ways uh
to think about this um one
analogy is think about it like
baking a cake when it comes to baking a
cake
you don't just need the right
ingredients
you also need the right environment you
need the right temperature
the right um meaning the oven preheated
up
you also need to do the steps in the
right order you don't put the frosting
down first
pile flour on top of it without mixing
it with yeast i don't know how to
bake a cake so whatever else you like
you have to do the things you don't put
the sprinkles on first you sprinkle the
sprinkles on the frosting once the cake
comes out
so you want to do the things in the
right order so the way to think about it
is the content you put on youtube
is sprinkles a little bit of frosting
is one stage is what temperature to put
the oven now
is how long to to set the oven for
and it's all these bits and pieces that
are all potentially in the course but
what are people investing in when
they're getting the course
they're investing in you this is a big
key about why the e-learning industry is
huge and why it matters to connect with
super fans
to connect with personality is people
want to learn from you
there's a lot of places to get the
information they're getting to know you
on youtube
they're getting to know you on youtube
they're getting to trust you on youtube
and then they're getting to say i want
josephine
to walk me through this so your online
course becomes
how to do all of the steps in the right
order
because that's also the key to success
so it's not actually
a matter like we don't hold back
information if you will on think
marketing or think media
but we just are giving out sprinkles and
frosting there's little there's some
stuff here there's some stuff there
when you join inner circle or video
ranking academy you know in inner circle
we have the 10 steps for building a six
to seven figure online business
you don't just get like we'll probably
talk about all ten of the steps on our
think marketing podcast we're probably
in season two so we'll be talking about
them at like
a surface level we'll be going through
them but when you go in inner circle
you're a member you know
we spend an hour to 90 minutes going
deep on just one of the steps
and on the thick marketing podcast we
spend we kind of do an introduction to
it
and so the course becomes the
comprehensive
a to z how to take you from
ingredients even what ingredients to buy
so even like what ingredients to buy
what tools you need to bake a cake how
to do all the steps
all the way through so that you have a
cake on the other side and here's what
ends up happening
like for some people they may want to
hang out with you
and they realize they could maybe piece
together your youtube videos
and at some level and be like i get most
of the ingredients
they might miss a step or two so that's
also just because
like in our program it just goes in
order and that's what people pay for
when they
get an online course is they actually
literally pay what what good is it to
start studying pre-calculus when you
haven't done the foundations
and you don't and we don't know what we
don't know so again we just put
everything into the course
in a linear teacher organized 101
2013141 whatever it is and then what we
do
is and maybe what i'm trying to convey
is that one of the most powerful things
you can do to build your brand
is is put frosting and sprinkles on
youtube because that's maybe the sexiest
stuff
but it's also this is what gets really
interesting about like what we do
is we talk a lot about like the sexiest
stuff on think because that's what
people also want to hear they want to
click on
how do i get views how do i get
subscribers how do i make money but then
what you learn in the course
is like the actual stuff that is
critical to success
but that people don't necessarily want
to learn
but they need to learn so let me hit you
with one other concept and let me know
if this is helpful
um it's called the chocolate covered
carrot when it comes to online marketing
and it's it's an ethical thing to do but
it's realizing that
most people don't want to eat carrots
they want to eat chocolate
so when it comes to marketing an online
course or if you will building an
audience that's watching youtube
most of what you talk about should be
chocolate because that's all
any of us really want is we just want to
eat chocolate and dessert right
so if we get out we're like how to reach
10 000 subscribers
work your freaking face off be massively
discouraged
do your push-ups eat your peas people be
like
f that what the heck are we talking you
know what i mean but it's it doesn't
invalidate the fact that there is the
chocolate
aspects of what we do but you know in
motherhood and whatever
there's the stuff that people uh
it's the problem they know they have is
the chocolate covered carrot
but it's also the problems they don't
know they have are covered in the course
so there's a lot of things that end up
being in the course where you might we
do some of this stuff we like to do
mindset work we're like now that you're
here
let's lay the foundation right first
that's how you build a cake
it's like listen you might have met us
because we were talking about sprinkles
and frosting
and trust us that's the end goal that's
where we're going to get you to
but hey now that you're here like we
tricked you ethically
into the course to make you eat your
vegetables
because as teachers and coaches that are
obsessed with
our community and our customers outcomes
we
would never withhold the truth true love
speaks the truth and like so it's like
so hey truth is
if you want to get the six-pack abs and
you want to get ripped you actually have
to like change
your diet and exercise and so it's like
hey now that you're inside the course
here's the deal mom here's the deal like
here's the
bs we have to deal with the belief
system we have to deal with
when it comes to like really getting
this motherhood thing right
here's the found here's the eight-week
foundational mindset training
theoretic you know whatever you're gonna
do that you need to get it right
and and maybe that aspect of it isn't
even what's talked about on the youtube
channel
and maybe it is maybe you even see some
of that but is this helping in terms of
two big concepts all the right steps in
the right order
in the right environment to do this
thing first a lot of the reasons why
people fail on youtube
is they do step 18 when they haven't
done step one two and three
right yet or they don't even know what
one step one two and three
is yet so it's all the right steps in
the right order
in the right environment at the right
time in your journey
in addition supported with potentially
downloads
worksheets other things that just a free
youtube video like this
you know supported with the community
that's probably one of the biggest
aspects of a paid course
is the private facebook group is the
deeper intimacy
is the fact that we do this as you know
inner circle at the end of every month's
training
where we bring people on and it's not
235 on facebook and however many on
youtube
but it's a smaller group so i hope that
encourages
it's not even that you still might be if
in a way teaching your best stuff
and teaching stuff that you're like well
what's free what's paid what's paid
is all the stuff in the right order all
the right steps the downloads and the
support of bonuses and resources
the community that comes along with it
and the trust that's been built with you
that people go i've just i'm sold like
i'm i'm
i realized like i can trust this person
and i want josephine to walk me through
a to z
even though and let me give you one
final concept
the baked cake analogy the chocolate
covered carrot analogy
youtube videos are what people want to
know and then
the carrot is what people need to know
and both are included in your course
and then i think uh maybe it escaped my
mind but the
um let me know is that helpful so
helpful thank you so much my mind is
blown right now
good good stuff thank you so much you're
awesome you're welcome josephine hey i
appreciate you so much
and when'd you join inner circle uh
less than a month ago i believe like
three weeks ago so i'm still going
through the
the course and everything like that yeah
what do you think about it so far it
okay i gotta say it is phenomenal
if you have not joined inner circle
listen
you are missing out like
okay if you can see how excited i am
this is why you should join inner circle
it's because
listen it gives you the tools and the
tips on what like it literally goes
deeper into what you talk about here so
this is like surface level
and then you think about vra and that
goes deeper and then you think about
inner circle that goes deep deep deep
in the roots so if you're thinking about
inner circle
dude it's amazing you should join like
and i just joined maybe a month ago and
it's like
my mind is blown so it's amazing i love
it
it's i'm super excited about it awesome
joseph
hey i appreciate your kind words and so
thankful you're part of the ic fam and
thanks so much for coming on the show
and coffee with kennel thank you
take care my friends
smash like you've been getting value out
of today's training and coffee with
kennel conversations
that was a good one so grateful that
josephine
came on and i hope that brought some
clarity to
uh those of you that are maybe thinking
about starting a membership
site starting a course and what i put in
the course and what i put inside
of uh the membership site what's free on
youtube
and um the chocolate covered carrot all
the right steps in the right order when
it comes to baking a cake
plus community plus downloads plus all
of those things
and if you want more information about
that
you can always hit us up you know if you
want to talk to somebody on the think
media team
talk with think dot com
is a place where you can learn more
about things like inner circle and video
ranking academy
it's called talk with think dot com
and uh we'd be happy if you're wondering
if one of our courses events or coaching
programs is right for you
let's talk you can just schedule a
discovery call
um and you pick a date on here and
schedule a time
and so that's talk with think dot com if
you
are um wanting some more training
specifically
on the next 60 day sprint when it comes
to
youtube um today's
coffee with candle is brought to you by
thinkmasterclass.com
my friends i have never been more
passionate and more certain
that uh youtube is good ground to invest
in
um what we've seen in 2020 is the
increased awareness of people
that were locked down didn't have a lot
to do of different generations
backgrounds and demographics
you know falling in love with online
content i was with my friend chris
johnston
um in his retirement legacy years uh he
actually took us out on his boat and we
were
uh kind of driving around uh in the san
juan islands up in washington
uh friends of ours from church from
years ago when we lived in seattle
and he was like i think you're on to
something with this youtube stuff
and i was like why do you say that and
he's like i've been watching a lot of
sailing videos i've been watching a lot
of sailing vloggers
and man i'm hooked and so this was
someone who didn't watch youtube
covet happens he is coming on i was
talking to another friend
who just bought some crab pots from
um costco and was getting into crabbing
up in the western washington and he said
i've been watching all these youtube
videos
not just about how to do crab pots about
where to go but he talked about
uh there's people that have the specific
spots in washington
rated uh when it comes to crab pots and
he's like i'm in
and i'm listening to these guys i'm
gonna do whatever they told me they're
my guide
they're my person that's helping me
solve this problem remember
what problem do you solve who do you
help
what is your what how do you do things
differently and why
are you doing it start with why and
think about those distinctions man
there's so much opportunity on youtube
yes there's competition but when the
mountain gets steeper you just get
fitter
you just get smarter you just get more
strategic and uh that's what we're here
to do at
the think media company we're here to
help and so if you want some niche
strategies
think masterclass.com link in the
description below go there right now
to um watch the uh
that that training you'll love it and
that'll get you ready for the 60-day
sprint
come on man i know there's more than 60
days in 2020 but when you subtract
weekends
when you subtract the last couple weeks
and the holidays
there's not much time left but you'd be
surprised how much you can get done
in 60 days if you
focus focus stands for follow one
course until successful right
one course one focus one strategy
get your strategy down get your mind
right your grind on your hustle fixed
your goals set and cut out the minutia
the heck is minutia sean cut out the
meaningless the non-essential stuff
and punt some stuff to 2021 what stuff
is being moved to next year
i got battles to fight but not this year
this year
this is what i'm focused on i'm getting
my video done a week i'm doing that
keyword research
i'm getting that i'm upgrading my gear
i'm learning how to use my gear i'm
learning how to edit video
i've got my focus fixed my friends
it's time to build so i appreciate you
hashtag 60daysprint
hashtag hit the like button thanks for
being a part of
coffeewithkannel kennel action takers
hashtag all in let's go miss cat moon
it's time to sprint
cut out the minutia cut out the meaning
list cut out the non-essential
follow one course until successful and
it is time
to grind all right my friends i
appreciate you see you in the next
coffee with kennel and until then keep
crushing it keep smashing it and we will
talk soon